I want to talk about the unions but
first I want to talk about Michelle moan
what's going on well there's a 200
million pound contract that was given to
PPE Med Pro that was recommended by
baroness Mon and that contract was an
absolute waste of money and it was
through the VIP Fast Track Lane which
was proven to be unlawful the way that
people were given a leg open
preferential treatment I mean this
company wasn't even formed it wasn't
even registered when baroness mon
approached ministers to to get this
contract so I want the documents to be
given to the Public Accounts committee
and for that money to be accountable I
want people to see what's happened there
how do you know it was a waste of money
because the 122 million pound that was
spent on gowns none of them could be
used eight to one million pound on face
masks that were paying over double what
these companies were making them for and
other companies were producing them less
than half the price so it was an
absolute waste of money and why was that
company given it whereas other companies
that could have delivered at the time
were not given contracts because they
wasn't on this VIP fast lane so who's
your beef with my beef is with the
government for they're the responsible
and the fact that it looks like cronyism
that they've just been given their mates
these contracts without any due
diligence that's why I'm calling the
vote today in Parliament to get to the
bottom of it we need to see the
documents and see what's happened this
is public money but we're in the middle
of a pandemic the government was doing
absolutely everything they possibly
could in order to try and keep people
safe some mistakes were going to be made
well I don't accept that I don't accept
that hole in the middle of a pandemic we
had loads of British companies that are
saying I want to help they've got
expertise in that area they've done
gowns before they've done maths before
and they weren't given the opportunity
to help they were frustrated and the
only thing that they didn't have was the
phone number WhatsApp or access to
government ministers government peers
and others who could get them on this
VIP Fast Track and the due diligence
clearly wasn't there because the list
level of incompetence 10 billion pound
wasted on PP that because out use so is
it Michelle moan that you're upset with
is it um the person that she first
approached as in Michael Gove or is it
the former Health secretary I think we
need to get to the bottom of exactly
what's happened I think it's a scandal
of a huge proportion that we've wasted
so many billions and it looks like
people were getting rich on the back of
what was the pandemic and I think that's
really sick actually I think you're
going to Public Service you're supposed
to do your best for the public this does
not sound like it was the best for the
public at the time we need those
documents in the open so people can see
and then I tell you who I'm more upset
with on who's who's been the one that's
been making the profit and you know
making money on the back of taxpayers on
the back of people's Misery we saw those
pictures of care workers and NHS workers
who couldn't get the right PPE at the
time and yet we had companies who were
desperate to try and help who had
experience told no we don't need you
some instances wouldn't even get back to
them and we had other companies this one
uh this um you know PP Med Pro they
wasn't even formed at the time when the
baroness mon was approaching Minister
saying give us a contract give us a
contract you know allegedly which I'm
going to throw allegedly in there just
to be on the south side yeah well I mean
again give us the documents if you
haven't done it if you're you haven't
done anything wrong then show us the
transparency in this you know why are
you being so evasive in terms of showing
the public what their millions of pounds
200 million pounds were spent on talk to
me about strikes
um rmt extending their strike action
um today
um every time I have one of your
colleagues here they say well we would
get around the table we'll and and do
what well in Wales we don't have
industrial action we've got industrial
action in the UK at the moment in
England on an industrial scale because
this government have been incredibly
militant with workers of this country
who have faced an absolute Pelton and
they see like the discussion I've just
done now about the billions that they've
wasted and then they told like at a lump
it this is what you've got to have we've
had transport ministers that wouldn't
speak to the transport unions and
regardless of the strike action you try
and get on the train in the north now
these companies are not delivering on
that contract whether it's strike days
or not they get paid it's the public
that have inconvenienced and these
workers that are taking industrial
action lose money every time they go on
strike so even if Mick Lynch the General
Secretary of the rmt was you know
militant as the government wants to
paint him and portray him he has to get
his workers the the union members to
agree to go out on your distraction
these people don't want to do that I
think there's a deal to be done I think
the government really do need to get
there yeah well you know the negotiation
around the new working conditions
reforms that you want to bring in the
unions have said we're up for that we'll
look at that it's about the pay that
they're being offered and the unions
have said you know we're ready for the
negotiations on that and I think that
the employers should be able to do that
they've got you know they're still
making huge amounts of profit on the
back of those contracts and they're not
delivering on those contracts do you
support the rmt Striking over Christmas
I support workers right to take
industrial action we have some of the
most restrictive industrial action
legislation in this country I believe
that if we had a labor government now we
wouldn't be in this situation in Wales
we've got a labor government we're not
in this situation when labor was last in
power we didn't have nurses taking
industrial action and we didn't have
this level of disruption it's this
government that have broken the system
completely and can't even get the train
operas operators without strike to run
the trains on time do you support the
rmt's taking strike action over
Christmas I think the rmt don't want to
take action I want to see that strike
action avoided I don't think anybody
dodging my question
I am always I don't want to see
industrial action because I see workers
losing their pain I see the public
inconvenienced I think there's a way of
us getting around the table and stopping
it whether it's Christmas or any other
time of year if you're working our
economy in the north is suffering
because our trains are not running
properly and people can't get to work
and businesses are really suffering as a
result of that I want to see our trains
running on time and the work has been
paired paid fairly and decently and I
think that there is a deal to be done to
get there what do you think about Labor
politicians being on the picket line
I don't have a problem with labor
politicians being on the music line but
I'd much prefer it as being in
government solving the industrial action
rather than you know placards on the
picket line I've done that I've been a
union rep I became a politician so that
I could avoid us getting in that
circumstance in in the first place I
have no problems in visiting a picture I
never have but I want us to my job now
as the deputy leader of the labor party
is to get into government and to promise
the UK that we all have this situation
because we'll have resolved it we'll
treat workers fairly with dignity and
respect my new deal for working people
will deliver that security and will
avoid us getting into this situation in
the first place you must be pleased that
the government's coming around to your
way of thinking about onshore wind
well yeah it's about time I mean there's
a lot of hot air out of the government
if we could capture that then we might
be getting somewhere but you know we've
had years of no no growth we've had
years of the problems that we've faced
on Renewables and this government have
been well behind the curve on dealing
with the issues you know our gas storage
facilities were you know given up in
2014 so we're at the mercy of the market
and hence why we're in this situation
we're in today and you'd be very happy
to have um a wind farm near you oh yeah
we've got some great fields near us you
know we've got saddle worth more we've
got you know Hartford Pike it's lovely
around there I mean look we've got to
get real we've got to have solutions to
to become self-sufficient on our energy
needs I'm not a NIMBY I do think we have
to move forward on that yes we have to
look at local planning conditions and
everything else but we've seen this with
housing again the government are failing
on housing because they're not able to
deliver what is a aspiration of how we
achieve what we need to do and this sort
of local like MPS not on my backyard you
can have it in your back Garden you can
have it over here now what we need is a
proper plan on how we can deliver on
Renewables and how we can deliver on
housing in the UK okay
um pretty impressive behind the decks at
the weekend yeah I didn't realize it was
going to go as viral as it look I have
my teenage Sons with me I had to look
super cool so um I did this charity
event where I was DJing and trans33
there you go
I'm just proving that all those grannies
out there we are super cool grannies
yeah I had the bus on yesterday and he
couldn't think of a song that he would
uh play I tried and tried he didn't have
one what do you think would be his song
okay a song Oh libertine something like
that okay
you know Libertines or something like I
don't think he's a prodigy I'm a huge
Prodigy fan right it was a it was from
my youth entrance was from my youth
that's kind of dance music is my my type
of music I think is probably more Indie
yeah I was saying football's coming home
probably would work for him yeah I think
he'd really like that one as well
wouldn't we all yeah about time yeah
fingers crossed you know Gareth
Southgate I remember when I was young he
was like oh no well we lost the penalty
now he's like redeeming himself and he's
like our hero he's done a great job
managing the team and fingers crossed
he's coming home will we beat France
um it's going to be tough but I think we
can and I'm in trouble with my Welsh
colleagues because when England played
well still the night I was getting a bit
too enthusiastic because the two
strikers for England were obviously ones
from my hometown of Stockport and
everyone's from wythenshaw so I was like
Manchester and winding up the Welsh so I
hope that my Welsh colleagues have
forgiven me and the Welsh will come
behind England now and that hopefully we
can win on Saturday
thank you